the scars of the war are still visible
even now almost 50 years later
for years visitors have been able to
move freely between the turkish north
and greek south of the island
the green line a buffer zone dividing
both is controlled by the u.n
nj grace and dania ejuba however are
stuck
the two cameroonians have been camped
out in nicosia's no-man's land since the
spring
[Music]
and grace who wants to remain anonymous
fled the political unrest in their
homeland
they reached the north of the island via
turkey
but their goal was to reach the republic
of cyprus in the south which is eu
territory but the authorities there say
they're overwhelmed referring to 36 000
illegal immigrants
and say its two reception centers are
full
if we allow these two people to submit
for asylum
i am 100 convinced that the next day
all these people that they are trying
now to cross regularly the green line
will come by buses
karitas a catholic relief agency runs an
office near the buffer zone
there's a line of people waiting for
help who managed to cross into the south
but they aren't much better off than the
two stranded cameroonians
many of them are homeless
without accommodation really everything
falls apart they will struggle with food
they will have with no sanitation they
will face medical problems they will not
have safety they will be exposed to
violence and it all just snowballs into
one big problem
meanwhile many greek cypriots are
feeling increasingly hostile towards the
new arrivals
it's a catastrophe for cyprus
we are a small island and
immigrants are coming here coming or
coming without an end
now the government plans to suspend the
right to asylum a fundamental right in
the european union
there has been a trend a number of
instances that have been observed since
may 2020
of of boats being
returned
back to the
country of this of embarkation these
were cases that concerned syrian
refugees coming from lebanon
grim prospects for ajuba and grace who
remain stranded
un workers and volunteers from both
sides continue to provide the couple
with bare essentials
the food they are giving us is difficult
to digest for us
we manage but it's not easy
we want those in charge to finally help
us leave this place
ejuba would like to study in cyprus
but so far all attempts to bring about a
solution have failed
and their weight in no man's land
continues